Welcome to Xentiment by Crunch.
This app lets you trade
social media sentiment.
Here's how it works.
Our AI scans social media,
analyzes historical sentiment
around the topics you care about,
and finds correlations
between that sentiment
and asset prices.
When a correlation exists,
we backtest a trading strategy
and show you the results.
Real P&L.
Real trades.
You start with a thesis.
Something like
"How bullish is Elon today?"
The app measures that sentiment
over time
and checks whether it's
historically predicted
Bitcoin price moves.
If it has,
you can trade on it.
Let's try it out.
I'll log in with my X account,
authorize the app,
verify my account,
and I'm in.
Now I click Earn Rewards.
Here's the interface.
Right now,
the tradable asset is Bitcoin
and the data source is X —
top minds.
More assets and data sources
are coming soon.
Let's ask:
"Is Elon bullish?"
We're measuring how bullish
Elon's sentiment has been
over time
and whether that maps
to price movement.
I'll hit submit.
The app is now scanning signals,
analyzing mentions,
and building out
the sentiment chart.
Here we go.
Three charts.
First:
the correlation between
our question's sentiment
and Bitcoin price moves.
We're seeing 10.9%,
which is actually
quite significant.
Second: the P&L.
Trading this strategy
with the paper trading capital
in my account
would have produced
$30,000 in profit.
Every user gets
paper trading capital
to test strategies
without risking real money.
Third: the actual trades.
Every position —
long, short, closed, reverse —
all driven by
the sentiment question
you created.
In this case,
three out of three
winning trades.
If you like the result,
click Paper Trade
to take the strategy live.
The algorithm now monitors
conditions in real time,
and when it finds
the right edge,
trades execute automatically.
Since we just activated,
there are no trades yet —
but once conditions align,
it will start.
You can check back
on this strategy
at any time.
You can grow your
paper trading capital
by sharing an invite link
to bring in new users,
or by sharing a trading card
that shows your expected P&L.
Both boost your points
and your capital.
Your dashboard shows everything:
ongoing strategies,
trade monitoring,
and the history of all
the questions
you've tested.
You can run multiple strategies
and compare performance.
There's also a leaderboard
ranked by invites
and strategy performance.
You earn capital boosts —
50K and 100K —
by testing strategies,
sharing trading cards,
and inviting users.
That's Xentiment.
Ask a question,
find the correlation,
trade the sentiment.